in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Troy is
with us hey Troy how are you I'm doing
amazing Dave how are you well I'm
honored it's good to have you sir where
do you live I live in Jacksonville
Florida born and raised very fun good
for you and you're here to do your
debt-free screen absolutely very cool
and how much have you paid off paid off
$42,000 love it and how long did that
take you 24 months very cool what do you
do for a living I'm a web application
developer for a marketing firm and I
also have a side business business where
I do voiceovers good for you good for
you and your income range it ranged from
50,000 at start to 68,000 at the end and
from the side business I'll also right
now doing about $75 Wow yeah that's nice
it is the side business is taken over it
has it's done pretty well for me
wonderful well congratulations very well
done
so tell me your story what happened 24
months ago well I should have to go back
a little bit further than that um when I
was I was pretty much a bum just living
at my parents house you know playing
video games all day basically no no
prospects whatsoever I then decided to
go back to college because I was pushed
to by my family when I second I step on
campus I was like you know what this is
your last shot you're gonna be working
minimum wage for the rest of your life
if you don't make this one happen mm-hmm
I made it happen I actually graduated
valedictorian Wow
yes yes I mean if you knew before that
that was like unfathomable wasn't it
but actually what degree did you get I
was a degree in web design and
development
no I didn't took to get a job with okay
and then so I'm seeing this paycheck
that has an extra zero at the end of it
who's I'd never seen that type of money
before in my life and I was like okay
well then I need to do right by this so
I immediately go onto the on sale online
and like start looking up everything I
can about personal finance I read it
every single blog read every single book
every soul all your book and through
that I happen to find you and your plan
and I was like this guy I know he's
talking about mmm he knows his stuff so
I was like okay I'm going to put this
plan to work in
for me in here I am there you go and 24
months later get that free absolutely
yeah apparently you can do anything you
set your mind to huh that's the thing
you know that's what I didn't realize
before but it's like you know you set
your mind to it you set yourself with a
up with a goal you can make anything
happen so was it your mom or your dad
that threw you out nobody threw me out
you're look too big to be thrown out but
yeah well I don't know if they can pick
me up to throw me up but yeah but my mom
pushed me to go back you know she and
she did it nicely you know it was with
you it was great you have too much
potential to be a couch potato yeah that
was pretty much it yeah that was a
conversation okay very cool well she was
obviously right she was and
congratulations to her for for pushing
the eagle out of the nest and making him
fly that's very well done how old are
you now I'm 32 32 so you started this
journey when you were 30 as far as the
debt goes that's right and when did you
go back to school at what age I went
back to school 28 at 28 okay so boom
boom just click click here we go
so the 40 mm was what what kind of debt
that was student loans a credit card and
a personal loan that I don't remember
what was for ah yes okay and there's a
people had those before I'll tell you so
so how does it feel now that I mean
you've had so much accomplishment in
your life in the last four years and one
of those things is to knock this debt
out but I mean you bet you got a lot of
traction in your life don't you yep so
far yeah if this is just the beginning
like I'm looking forward to the future
and like it's it's so open now yeah it's
like I've cracked down the door and now
I can go anywhere and then all I needed
was that low push for my mom and you
know
thank you mom appreciate it hey man hey
man well that's good stuff very well
done so I if there's a young person out
there that whose mom has not thrown them
I mean HUD suggested they leave out
there talk to them about what you've
been through and how it changed the
whole chemistry of who you are well
actually I have been talking to them I
just recently gave you a financial talk
at my alma mater speaking to college
students teaching them how
not to do what I did which is waste your
life and how to get out of debt and just
realize that you don't have to have
those student loans for the rest of your
life you know I mean get rid of those as
soon as possible and I mean it just it
just opens up so many opportunities for
you so I'm speaking to them they're
asking me questions and they're like
you're treating me like I'm the
financial expert I'm like well how did
this happen how did we get here but I
mean you can do it it's just about
setting your mind to it so what are the
keys to getting out of debt that you use
what do you think the things that
allowed you to do this it 42000 paid off
in 24 months the one thing is that I
think back to a quote that you made and
it was the rich know the same things you
and I know but the differences they do
it and I did it I just put it into
practice because everybody out here
everybody listening to the show right
now and knows exactly how to get out of
that everybody knows exactly how to get
financial freedom problem is almost
nobody does it if you just like just
listen and take my example or anyone's
example who's gotten out of debt I mean
just live on less than you may have a
plan
you know don't borrow money it's I mean
it's really that simple and it's as long
as they put it into practice they can go
wherever they need it yep there you go
it's it really is not rocket science it
really is so easy to understand and you
know I think that's what trips people up
because they want something complicated
absolutely and some of the most profound
life-changing things that you'll ever
learn in your life are simple to
understand but very hard to do because
they involve you changing the man in the
mirror absolutely and that's what you've
done right you know you left the couch
and went out here and completely changed
your whole life you're a hero man I'm so
proud of you congratulations
you think very well done I know your mom
and dad are proud of you valedictorian
debt-free all in a series of four years
very cool very cool I think we need to
hire you to do Web Apps for us but you
need to move you up here from
Jacksonville all right okay so we're
going to give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's new number one best-selling book
retire inspired signed by him because
that's your next step
build wealth and be outrageously
generous and you'll be right on that
path I can see that coming so very proud
of you Troy congratulations thank you do
good job Troy from Jacksonville Florida
$42,000 paid off in 24 months making
fifty to sixty eight oh and the little
side job that makes 75 K so count it
down let's there a debt free scream
three two one havin the crowd in the
lobby goes wild I love it that's great
Troy very good talking to you man
that's inspiring stuff right there hey I
meet Millennials that are that guy
everywhere everybody gives these
Millennials a hard knock I got a whole
bunch I'm working in this building and
they're that guy they know they can
spell initiative they they believe in
capitalism they believe in hard work and
discipline to win I meet these people I
you know I see them everywhere now I
know there's a percentage of these
Millennials that are just you know
socialist Bernie followers I get that
but I got to tell you that's not most of
them I don't even know if it's half of
them I I don't know what the numbers are
but I see enough of that kind that I got
a lot of hope for the future of this
country I really do now you wouldn't get
hope necessarily from the political
cycle but you can meet Troy I mean Fela
dick Torian man
I mean Gaza stud he's a stud man you see
I mean that guy's incredible that's
awesomeness and so you know you
listening to me you're 25 years old
you're 24 years old you're 27 years old
and you haven't done anything well now
is your day man he just told you he went
he just got up off the couch went
changed his whole life he put the
Nintendo down I went you know put halo
down and went to work man you know and
unless you're are a gamer for a living
there's no money in that crap you know I
want valedictorian web designing gaming
didn't anything do with that
- man why though those people are
incredible you can do this stuff you can
do this stuff the secrets of the rich
are not secrets the secret is it know
just what he's it nobody does it normal
is broke
normal is broke don't be normal just
decide you live in the richest country
the world has ever known
don't be normal this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a $500,000 ending